بإخراج سينمائي وحركات هوليودية
مجنون كوريا يستعرض صاروخه البالستي
العابر للقارات هواسنغ ١٧،
كيم أشرف بنفسه على عملية إطلاق الصاروخ
الوحش من مطار بيونغ يانغ،..
واليابان تعلن حالة الطوارئ بعد سقووط
أحد صواريخ المجنون في سواحلها،،..
أمريكا هي الهدف
لكن الرعب يدب في كوريا الجنوبية واليابان،
فهل يكونان حقل التجارب لكيم جونغ،
دولتان من كبريات دول العالم
تخشيان مجنونا يمتلك أقوى أسلحة العالم المدمرة....
مُخْلِصة بوتين امرأة تُخّلص روسيا من أزمة العقوبات،،،
الرئيس الأمريكي يهدد موسكو كالعادة
فهل يتمسك بتهديده أم يتراجع عنه؟..
زيلينسكي يطلب دعماً وضمانات جديدة
وبايدن يصل بولندا كأول وجهة
ضمن جدول حافل باللقاءات مع قادة الغرب،
فهل من جديد؟ أما الأمم المتحدة
فتحذر من تداعيات الحرب على المنطقة العربية،،،
(أسلحة مرعبة)
ترسانة نووية مخيفة ومتنامية لكوريا الشمالية.
مع صواريخ عابرة للقارات
تصل إلى الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
بيونغ يانغ تصب كل جهودها في انتاج الصواريخ
بعيدة المدى والهدف دائما الوصول إلى بر أمريكا..
وأبرز هذه الصواريخ:
صاروخ هواسونغ١٤ أول صاروخ باليستي
عابر للقارات يصل مداه إلى ١٠آلاف كم،
ويصل ارتفاعه تقريبا إلى٣آلاف كم ..
وتقول كوريا الشمالية أنه قادر على ضرب
أي مكان في الأرض
بينما تنفي أمريكا هذه القدرات للصاروخ..
فهل يتم تجريبه لضرب الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
ليؤكد المجنون كلامه؟
بينما صاروخ هواسونغ١٥، يحلق بارتفاع
٤٥٠٠كم، ويصل مداه إلى١٣ألف كم
ليأتي ما هو أعظم:
صاروخ هواسونغ١٧ (الوحش) ،
وهو أقوى أسلحة كيم جونغ على الإطلاق،
وهو مصمم لحمل عدة رؤوس نووية،
لأجل إرباك منظومات الدفاع الجوية
وهناك الكثير والكثير من الصواريخ
لدى مجنون كوريا الشمالية فلا تحاولوا استفزازه
أيها الأمريكان فالمجنون لا يمزح!!
(فعلها المجنون)
جيشا كوريا الجنوبية واليابان:
كوريا الشمالية أطلقت صاروخا يشتبه أنه بالستي
عابر للقارات، واليابان تؤكد سقوطه
في الساحل الغربي لهوكايدو....،
وهي ثالث تجربة تجريها بيونغ يانغ هذا الشهر،
وسط تنديد أميركي وبريطاني.
ورغم العقوبات الدولية الصارمة المفروضة عليها،
مضت كوريا الشمالية قدما في تحديث قدراتها
العسكرية.
وكان إطلاق هذا الصاروخ
هو التجربة الـ13 على الأقل التي تجريها
كوريا الشمالية لصواريخ باليستية هذا العام،
وهي وتيرة غير مسبوقة ...
(المرأة الفولاذية)
المرأة الحديدية لبوتين وحارسة خزائن روسيا،
إلفيرانابيولينا،
خبيرة الاقتصاد الروسية، يلقبها الروس
بمخلصة بوتين
وصفت بأنها أكثر نساء العالم نفوذا
تولت رئاسة البنك المركزي الروسي
عام ٢٠١٣
وفي ٢٠١٧
أعاد الدوما ترشيحها لولاية ثانية..
لكن هذه المرة بوتين بنفسه يرشحها
لولاية ثالثة على غير العادة
وتقول التقارير أن نابيولينا ساهمت بشكل جزأي
في الخروج من أزمة العقوبات عقب ضم القرم
كما أدرجتها مجلة فوربس مرات عدة
ضمن قائمة تصنيف أقوى امرأة في العالم
(التطورات والأحداث)
الانفصاليون يعلنون مقتل ٥٨ جنديا أوكرانيا
في دونيتسك
أمريكا تفرض عقوبات جديدة على ٤٠٠
فرد وكيان روسي
كتيبة الشيخ منصور
محاربون شيشانيون مسلمون،
قاتلوا ضد روسيا عدة مرات،
وهم يقاتلون مع الجيش الأوكراني ضد روسيا..
موسكو تعلن استسلام ٦٧ جنديا أوكرانيا
للقوات الروسية في العاصمة كييف
ماكرون: حلف الناتو قرر دعم أوكرانيا
بالأسلحة الدفاعية دون الدخول في الحرب..
مع تأكيده على ضرورة الجلوس على طاولة
المفاوضات والتوصل إلى حل سلمي
رئيس روسيا السابق ميدفيديف :
"اضطرت روسيا إلى إجراء العملية العسكرية
بأوكرانيا لأن الأهداف التي وضعتها الدولة
الروسية نصب عينيها لم يتم تحقيقها
بالطريقة الدبلوماسية".
وأشار ميدفيديف إلى أن أوكرانيا يجب أن تعتمد
نظام الحياد ولا تنتهج السياسة المعادية لروسيا.
ونوه إلى أن العملية العسكرية الروسية بأوكرانيا
تجري وفقاً للخطة التي وضعها الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين.
...
بايدن: الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
سترد إذا استخدمت روسيا أسلحة كيميائية،
وبريطانيا تفرض حزمة عقوبات على كيانات
روسية وبيلاروسية
زيلنسكي يطالب الناتو بإيصال أسلحة لبلاده
منها راجمات الصواريخ والدفاع الجوي
لافروف: الغرب دفع كييف لحل أزمة
إقليم دونباس عسكريا
وتجاهل قتل آلاف المدنيين في دونباس
من قبل القوات الأوكرانية،
وفرض حصارًا على المنطقة.
مشاهد لتدمير منظومة إس ٣٠٠ الأوكرانية
المضادة للطائرات
الأمين العام للناتو ستولتنبرغ: روسيا تبحث
عن ذرائع لاستخدام الأسلحة الكيميائية
في أوكرانيا من طريق اتهام الولايات المتحدة
وحلفائها بأنهم يستعدون لشنّ مثل هذا الهجوم،
مؤكداً أن الحلف سيزود أوكرانيا
بمعدات حماية من التهديدات الكيميائية
والبيولوجية والنووية،
...
الرئيس الروسي السابق دميتري ميدفيديف
يصف العقوبات الغربية المفروضة
على بلاده بأنها "غبية"
...
الرئيس الأوكراني يطالب الناتو باتخاذ
ضمانات حقيقية للسلام في أوكرانيا
وصل الرئيس الأميركي جو بايدن
إلى مدينة جيشوف بجنوب شرق بولندا
والتي تبعد قرابة 100 كلم عن الحدود مع أوكرانيا.
ورغم العقوبات المالية على روسيا،
قال بايدن: "لم أقل في الحقيقة أن العقوبات
ستردع (بوتين). العقوبات لا تردع"،
قائلاً إن العقوبات تهدف للتصدي للغزو الروسي
ولـ"زيادة المعاناة" على نظام بوتين.
في مجلس الأمن روسيا والصين يصوتان
لصالح مشروع قرار في أوكرانيا لكنهما
لم ينجحا في تمرير هذا القرار
لعدم وصوله للعدد الكافي للتصويت
بينما امتنع ١٣ عضوا عن التصويت..
زيلينسكي لحلف الناتو:
أنتم فرضتم عقوبات، ونحن ممتنون لكم.
هذه خطوات قوية. لكن الأوان كان متأخراً قليلاً.
لقد كانت هناك فرصة"،
مضيفاً أنها لو كانت عقوبات وقائية
فربما لم تشن روسيا تلك الحرب.
وأضاف أن إغلاق خط أنابيب الغاز
"نورد ستريم-2"، حيث قال إنه لو حُظر
من قبل فإن "روسيا ما كانت لتخلق أزمة غاز".
وحث زيلينسكي على الموافقة على طلب أوكرانيا
للانضمام إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي، قائلاً
"الآن أطلب منكم - لا تتأخروا!!
مشاهد للحظة استهداف صواريخ باستيون وكاليبر
الروسية لمنشآت أوكرانية
...
الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة. يحذر
من تأثير الحرب في أوكرانيا على دول عربية،
فهذه الدول تستورد ما لا يقل عن نصف قمحها
من أوكرانيا أو روسيا
وأضاف جوتيريز، الحرب تستنزف الموارد
وتشتت الانتباه عن بؤر توتر أخرى كاليمن...
كيم جونغ يستغل انشغال أمريكا بأزمة أوكرانيا
ويطلق صواريخه لتجريبها فهل تكون
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية أولى أهدافه مستقبلا؟
وماذا بعد أيها المجنون؟